hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring come at you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
let's get started in this video we're
gonna be talking about parallel lines
transversals and the angles that are
formed when you have lines cut by
transversals so let's get right into it
we're gonna be talking about
corresponding angles alternate interior
angles alternate exterior angles
consecutive interior angles and vertical
angles and just talk about the
relationships between all those
different types so the first thing that
you've probably learned in your math
class if you haven't already is when you
have two parallel lines okay so these
don't cross they keep going like that
cut by a third line they call it a
transversal at transverses or cuts
across those two lines you can see that
there's a angles that are formed now
let's go over the different types of
angles so corresponding angles what
corresponding angles means is that if
you were to take this axe see how it
forms like an axe there and pick it up
and place it on this X down here the
angles that match up or correspond
they're going to be congruent they're
gonna be equal to each other so angle
two is going to correspond with angle
six you can think of it as the upper
right hand corner matches up with upper
right hand corner upper left upper left
lower left lower left lower right lower
right so those are called corresponding
angles and they're congruent which means
that they're going to be equal now the
next one alternate interior angles
interior means they're in between
they're on the inside of these two
parallel lines right alternate means
ones on the left ones on the right so
three and six are gonna be alternate
interior angles four in five are
alternate interior angles and they're
congruent which means that these are
equal to each other and these are equal
to each other so if you think about the
name and what the name represents
that'll help you to figure out which
angles you're working with okay so
alternate exterior angles exterior these
are the ones that are on the outside
they're not in between the parallel
lines they're on the outside exterior
alternate means ones on the left ones on
the right so one in eight are alternate
exterior two and seven are alternate
exterior and those are going to be
congruent
to each other these are congruent and
these are congruent okay now consecutive
interior okay
this one's a little bit different this
is where students sometimes get a little
bit confused because up to this point
we've been talking about angles that are
congruent or equal right
but consecutive interior consecutive
means like one after another interior
means they're in between the lines right
these angles actually are supplementary
they add up to 180 okay so spoiler
alert' right so three and five goes down
up to 180 four and six those add up to
180 doesn't mean that they're both 90
this could be you know 120 this could be
60 but they're gonna add up to 180 all
the other ones that we've talked about
so far even including this last one
vertical angles those angles are
congruent to each other so vertical is
like when you see two lines they form an
X that cross each other okay like this
the ones that are across from each other
are going to be equal so 1 & 4 are equal
2 and 3 are equal those are vertical 6 &
7 5 & 8 so whenever you see two lines
crossed like in an X like that the ones
across from each other are equal those
are vertical now you don't have to have
two parallel lines cut by a transversal
to have corresponding angles alternate
into your angles and so on and I'll show
you that in this next diagram here so
see if you can work along with me here
and see if you can beat me to the punch
line here okay we're finding out what
these angles are called so notice we've
got four lines here right okay and let's
just see if we can find some
corresponding angles okay now remember
what we talked about with corresponding
angles if I was to take this X pick it
up place it on top of this X you're
gonna see that angle one is gonna match
up with angle five now because these two
lines are not parallel angle 1 and angle
5 are not going to be congruent to each
other they're still called corresponding
angles though so that's important thing
to distinguish if the lines are parallel
then the corresponding angles are
congruent the lines are not parallel
they're not congruent but again still
call corresponding angles 2 in 6 3 & 7 4
& 8 I'll just give you a half a second
here can you see any other corresponding
angle pairs okay two angles that are
corresponding well you could do the same
thing with this X here and this X here
right so 9 and 13 10 and 14 and so on
you could do that with this X and this X
right you do that with this X and this X
but what we can't do is we can't take
this X here and place it on top of this
X here okay do you see the difference
these angles are not corresponding with
these angles so what you have is you
have two lines cut by a transversal okay
now if you were to take this whole
diagram and rotate it same thing you
have these two lines cut by this
transversal these are the eight angles
that we're working with okay in terms of
the corresponding angles let's look at
alternate interior angles can you see a
pair of alternate interior angles in
this diagram well you can see 3 & 6 so
you have these two lines that are
in-between ones on the left ones on the
right alternate interior 4 & 5 right now
again they're not going to be congruent
like we talked about in this diagram
because the lines aren't parallel but
they're still called alternate interior
same thing over here if you kind of tilt
your head or rotate the diagram or turn
your computer you'll be able to see that
2 and 11 4 & 9 those are also alternate
interior you can say 12 and 13 11 and 14
alternate interior and you can keep
going through the diagram like that
for all the other different types of
angles we talked about up here but let's
look at this next example here in this
example what we're gonna do is we're
gonna try to find out what X is in this
diagram now I just want to point out
when you see these little arrows like
that okay not necessarily at the end of
the line but like you know somewhere in
between the two ends of the line this
indicates that the lines are parallel
see these arrows right here so what we
have is L and M are parallel and they're
cut by this transversal and this
transversal P right so what's the
connection between this angle for X and
this angle 120 if you guessed alternate
exterior angle is your right and what do
we know about alternate exterior angles
they're congruent so all we have to do
is set for X equal to 120 and we can
solve for X so that comes out to 30
right so for x equals 120 X is 30 over
here what's the connection between this
angle and this angle okay well if you
guessed alternate interior angles you're
right and these angles are congruent so
you just have to set them equal to each
other so 3 X plus 2 equals 110 and you
can solve for X so I hope you learned
some
in this video go ahead and subscribe to
the channel I look forward to seeing you
some of the future videos and I'll talk
to you soon